[Music]
joining the highly anticipated return of
an animated Spider-Man movie is another
kind of man but much more spooky plus a
romantic date night option a sketch
comedy show that critics adore in a
season finale from one of the most
biscuit-centric comedies on TV we've
lassoed up some great Wrecks for you on
this week's what to watch Being
Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saved in every World
swinging into theaters is the sequel
film Spider-Man across the spider-verse
five years have passed since the
animated Spider-Man into the
spider-verse became somewhat of a
surprise hit racking up a certified
fresh 97 on the Tomato Meter and this
time to less surprise we're happy to
report that across the spider-verse is
also certified fresh currently at 96
forecasting Good Vibes for the
inevitable third installment beyond the
spider-verse due out and next year
another reason to hurry up and see this
one is that Miles Morales AKA Spider-Man
will be venturing out as this film
showcases at least six spider verses
with each having its own distinct look
think of the world of 2099 in one
dimension and the 1970s Japanese
Spider-Man show in another of course
with all that comes new spider Heroes
too and joining returning Stars shamique
Moore Haley Steinfeld and Jake Johnson
will be names like Issa Rae Daniel
kaluya and Oscar Isaac who's Spider-Man
2099 had a brief Cameo at the end of the
first movie and is playing a larger part
in this one you're both having these
manifestations
[Music]
creeping into theaters is the
supernatural horror flick the boogeyman
yes a horror movie in June this one is
about a terrifying entity that preys on
the suffering of a family who just lost
their mother slash wife and is based on
Stephen King's 1973 short story of the
same name and that right there may very
well be reason enough to check this one
out but it's also worth noting that this
creeper was written for the screen by
Scott Beck and Brian Woods who wrote a
quiet place and Mark Heyman who wrote
Black Swan we call that qualified for
the job the boogeyman is at a
respectable 65 percent on the Tomato
Meter and a consensus from the critics
saying that while it may not live up to
the source material it's got a spooky
atmosphere and some solid performances
plus you know it's a horror movie in
June
okay
[Music]
another theatrical option this week
comes by way of the romance drama past
lives this film is about two childhood
friends who reunite as adults for one
fateful week where they explore ideas of
Destiny and love in what has been
described as a heart-wrenching modern
romance along with an interesting
premise another reason to look at past
lives is that it stars Greta Lee she's
had a steady career but recently broke
through by stealing her scenes in Apple
TV's Morning Show and now she's getting
a much deserved starring role the film
was directed by celine's song in her
directorial debut which has made all the
more impressive by the fact that it's
certified fresh currently at 96 with an
audience score of 91 AKA it's good
Showtime
[Music]
a strong streaming option for this week
is season three of I think you should
leave with Tim Robinson this sketch
comedy series was co-created by and
stars actor Tim Robinson for the main
premise of each segment is to try and
drive someone to the point that they
want to leave gotta love the originality
Robinson was previously a writer on SNL
and that connection remains with plenty
of hilarious guest stars stopping by
like Andy Samberg Cecily Strong and Will
Forte to name a few the first two
seasons are certified fresh at 96 and
100 so they ain't messing around with
last season's critics consensus calling
it a Triumph of sketch comedy enough
said
sometimes
I love you guys so very much I'm three
one two three
[Applause]
and finally also streaming this week is
the season three finale of Ted lasso
while it's coming at the end of a third
straight certified fresh season which is
reason enough to catch this episode it's
even more important because this could
be the end of the show itself star and
co-creator Jason Sudeikis has said that
this all began as a three season Arc and
that's how the third season was
approached so while the show may still
continue we can at least say this story
arc is ending and that's something
season 3 was a little slower for cricks
to get into but they eventually got on
board the consensus heading into the
final episode is that viewers who
believe will find that they appreciate
coach as much as ever well do you
believe
okie dokie fresh friends that's five saw
directs to give you that much needed
mental break this week be sure to let us
and your fellow viewers know in the
comments what you did check out whether
it was on this list or not remember to
check out rottentomatoes.com for the
latest updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay fresh
foreign